welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B with another MCU throwback
Thursday now Angela Bassett made history
on Tuesday by being nominated for best
supporting actress in Black Panther
wakanda Forever This is the first MCU
movie to receive an Academy Award
nomination for acting but not the first
MCU movie to receive an Academy Award
nomination that goes to Iron Man which
was nominated for best sound design in
2008 but lost to the Dark Knight now the
first MCU movie to win an Academy Award
is of course Black Panther the original
and that one for best score best
production design and best costume
design now black panther wakanda forever
is up for five Oscars this year Angela
bassett's best supporting actress
nomination it's also for best original
song Lift Me Up which was co-written by
Ryan coogler so that guy could take home
some trophies this year well deserved in
my opinion black panther wakanda forever
rooting for you at the Oscars this year